yesterday was a big day for us John Tesh
and Mary Hart returned to host ET we had
a great time with them and how about
this Mary and John reminiscing about day
one of their TV partnership do you
remember your first day on the show I do
well you know we just happen to have dug
out of the vaults for that very first
day so take a look at this John Tesh
will be sitting in this seat from now on
and it sure is fun to be working with
you now it's great to be here on my
favorite show with my favorite gal I
think I think I wrote that down you know
but you can see my legs are like going
like this and I am i holding my hands
like like this but you were you were
very gracious from the very beginning
and you know what I like we're both a
whole lot more blonde now than we were
then yeah yes but we're much more
natural now we really had a brother and
sister relationship and that was so fun
for me all eyes are focused on this guy
called Oscar ten years together dozens
of award shows but what I didn't know
was that John almost got fired because
of me hey listen we're sending you to
body language school and I said no
you're not and I said yeah if you want
to keep your job
you're gonna go to body language school
in Dallas for four days I said well why
isn't because you're not being nice to
Mary and I said we talked about I love
Mary and I think I was just trying to be
hip or something like they put my tongue
in my cheek whatever join us tomorrow
for the inside story on Elvis Presley's
mystical beliefs you know I'd roll my
eyes at a story or something too and
they said it's coming off like you're
you're not happy with me don't like - OH
we're rolling all right so I got the
body language school and they had all
these tapes of these like 15-second
segments of me after stories and they
and they edited them all together and
sure enough I was being a jerk
that's like a producers thing right guys
decide to become a different person and
I did and that's why I had so much
respect for you because you put up with
me
we all saw a change in John in the
middle of his decade-long run on ET
that's when he met his future wife
actress Connie sellecca
little puppy dog Jon falling in love
yeah I was a I was a bowl of mush oh it
was it was great to see and and then of
course I remember when prema was born
she is every bit as beautiful as her mom
look at these legs
these legs aren't sure for 1 million
dollars each new job and look how that
beautiful baby has grown up here is your
gorgeous gorgeous Prima it's so nice to
see you here today with your dad preme I
love you you know she looks a lot like
her mom thank God that yeah we got
really blessed with that
John said goodbye to et in 1996 to focus
on his music career full-time he has
four gold albums and two Grammy
nominations in his new book relentless
John shares his near death battle with
prostate cancer he says he owes his good
health to faith and is very much looking
forward to the future it's pretty
unbelievable John we've been sitting
here we have laughed together we've
almost shed a few tears together but
it's just great to see you again
that's my honor to be with you mine too
[Music]